man I got nothing quippy to say in the
beginning let's just talk about the
heavy movie of the week or year
[Music]
so sound of freedom is a movie little
setup here I'd never even heard about
this movie until a couple days ago saw
it in the comment section people were
like why don't you review sound of
freedom I was like what's that I what is
that turns out it's not what it sounds
like it I mean sound to Freedom sounds
like a 2002 war in Iraq military puff
Piece Film right it's not sound to
Freedom is based on a true story it
stars Jim Caviezel as Tim Ballard who's
an agent for Homeland Security and this
movie is the true story about how this
guy Tim Ballard worked with colleagues
got some funding set up a sting
operation to catch a bunch of these
traffickers and free a bunch of children
from trafficking now the first 45
minutes or so of this movie is exposing
you to the horrific nature of the
subject matter and it needs to do that I
totally get that that is to say this
film is very heavy this is not like
taken taken is using a real thing human
trafficking and that's the springboard
to show Liam Neeson be a badass and
smoke baddies and that's why we love
them for it and that's why the movie's
entertaining this is not that this is a
very real look at the world of child
trafficking not to say it's graphic it's
a PG-13 movie I appreciate that about it
we know what happens to these children
when they're trafficked we don't need to
see it I like the fact that the film
knows that you don't have to show it to
Nelly also makes it more accessible for
people you know it's like you got to
have a strong stomach already just
thematically to watch this film they
were graphic I'd dude I'd have bailed
but I appreciate that it shows that this
world of chasing child traffickers these
agents have seen the worst of the worst
I would say it's not a job for everybody
I would argue it's not a job for anybody
they do it because if they don't who
will there's an emotional toll that it
takes and that is why Jim Caviezel is
perfect in this film he's perfect
because I've always seen him as a person
the first time I really saw Jim cavieza
was frequency I was he just has a kind
face yes I know he has played villains
before but to me I don't know maybe I
still see him as Jesus but he has a kind
face however he has really pained eyes
his eyes just have this look about him
like he's dealing with a lot of pain but
trying to hide it perfect for the
character character he always looks like
he is one sentence away from just
breaking down and crying but he still
has that switch flipped and really
that's largely all of us in the audience
we're like that so it's kind of it was
relatable to see Jim Caviezel be like
the rest of us us be like Jim Caviezel
if you don't cry in the movie you did
actively try to hold it back no one's
judging anyone here I'm just saying
that's the logistical fact also they use
the budget really well in here the movie
costs about 14.5 million dollars thus
saith the Googles Incredible use of
budget if I found out this movie cost
twice as much as that like 30 million
dollars I'd be like yeah that tracks
also they made the most of their budget
that's actually really impressive it
costs less than half of that at 14.5
million dollars I have seen movies with
60 million dollar budgets look far
cheaper than this movie ever did if you
dare to look into the facts of the true
story of this you do see where they
trimmed the budget I guess the main
operation Opera operation triple
want to call it triple tap I don't think
that's it triple take right so operation
triple take was much larger they
actually saved a lot more people but for
the sake of the film they were like
let's concentrate on the children that
they saved those kind of Corners cut you
see where they were like if we had a
larger budget maybe we can show the
whole thing but we can't show how large
scale that operation was you don't know
that you don't know until you start the
Googling afterwards but the fact that
this movie makes you look into it more
makes you start googling that's a good
thing I also like I feel like this is
going to be a concern for some people so
I guess the studio don't know much about
it but I heard it's a faith-based studio
also it's called the sound of Freedom
point is in this politically charged
world I'm sure some people look at this
and be like right wing whatever no
thanks but I felt it did a really good
job at keeping that out of it it's not
about that it's not about the right
versus the left it's about saving
children like there are lines in the
movie where Jim Caviezel says God's
children are not enough for sale first
of all pretty badass frame days but it's
in context it's the characters what he
would say it's what the guy would say so
it makes sense in the context of the
film and the character at hand but this
is based off of a true story so yeah
there was a clear moment where I was
like I do not think it happened this way
gonna look into it exactly it's like the
movie wraps up and it felt a little
quick on the wrap up but I was like all
right you know it's fine didn't have a
big budget after all and then it was
like you know what what if this dude
just does a solid snake sneaking
operation into the jungle for one last I
was like
it feels weirdly out of place to the
point where I feel like they had their
movie and it was all wrapped up and the
sting goes down and someone was like
no big metal gear solid fan I don't
think that movie's ever happening so
this is the closest we will get let's do
it for the sake of the fundamental
wrap-up of
fulfillment I will say it's a two hour
15 minute film it did not feel like it
was over two hours so that's really
impressive these days I really feel the
run time I'm getting old and grumpy when
it comes to run times no doubt I'm
completely aware of it just so you know
so it's actually more impressive I
didn't notice it here I would be remiss
if I went without talking about the
musical score I thought the musical
score was exceptional it was heartfelt
beautiful emotional all when called for
on the other hand Broody dark intense
atmospheric somber downright creepy in
other scenes but in the end in a weekend
of packed movies I wasn't planning on
doing this one but glad I did it's an
informative film that's a solid Thriller
in its own right that's all I ask if a
film exists to be informative I only ask
that it also be entertaining in the
genre that it is in I felt this film did
that again heavy subject matter so if
this is a one-time viewing totally get
it but I do believe it is worth that one
viewing it emotionally sticks with you
and I'm glad I watched it no alcohol
that's why all right so sound to Freedom
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]